[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginez vous dormir avec moi
du calme j'ai bien dit dormir il y a
cinq ans une nuit avec moi c'était un
véritable cauchemar dans le meilleur des
cas vous auriez eu droit à une version
peu articulée et extrêmement forte de
l'alphabet chanter vous connaissez
accompagné de hurlements façon exorciste
empli de désespoir et d'agacement
ponctuée de ranger vos étés 0
ma vie professionnelle impact est
gravement la qualité de mon sommeil
car oui
le jour
j'enseignais en maternelle
moi qu'il ne supportait pas qu'on
empiète sur ma sfere vitol voilà que je
me retrouve avec des enfants de 4 ans et
tout ce que ça implique ça pleure ça
piaille ça court dans tous les sens et
pour un oui ou pour un non ça veut se
coller à moi d'ailleurs le premier jour
j'ai refusé leurs câlins et je leur ai
froidement tendu la main en guise de
bonjour
un vrai cauchemar des jour comme de nuit
mes premières années je les ai
véritablement subi j'avais envie de
m'enfuir de tout abandonner les élèves
étaient bien trop dur bien trop
imprévisible je passais plus de temps à
gérer des conflits et des comportements
carelman enseignants j'ai passé mes
soirées à chercher des solutions
en 2019 j'ai eu l'opportunité de
participer à une formation sur la base
du volontariat de cinq jours il était
question de permettre aux enseignants de
développer plus de sérénité et confiance
en adoptant une communication efficace
dans la glace hockey
moi je ne suis surtout dit que j'allais
avoir 5 jours de répit
de cette formation ce que je retiens
catherine ou nathalie d'ailleurs ça ne
revient pas en tout cas une femme
rayonnante chaleureuse à l'ecoute
convaincu par son approche de la vie
pour elle il était question de besoin
satisfait ou non et d'émotion qui comme
des signaux nous alerter sur ses besoins
ok
moi les émotions jusque là j'avais
surtout appris à l'éther et maintenant
on me demandait d'apprendre à les
reconnaître
allez ressentir allait s'exprimer et à
permettre à mes élèves d'en faire autant
vous vous imaginez vous demandez à un
enfant de 4 ans
quelles émotions ressenties ce matin
quels besoins non satisfaits te mets
dans un tel état
encore un truc complètement à côté de la
plaque
pourtant l'idée a fait son petit
bonhomme de chemin pourquoi pas pourquoi
ne pas permettre à mes élèves
d'apprendre à identifier leurs émotions
j'ai utilisé le temps de lecture
quotidien pour aborder et présenter les
émotions
rien gagné 9 ans il est particulièrement
demandé aux enseignants d'utiliser ces
séances pour permettre aux élèves de
mieux s'identifier avec les personnages
j'ai donc commencé par lister les
émotions vécues dans la classe et j'ai
cherché les albums qui les avorter
chaque jour a été l'occasion de
découvrir la tristesse du loup les
joueurs de trop trop l'entousiasme de
paix pas de son petit frère georges
ça vous parle
en quelques semaines seulement j'ai pu
constater que les élèves étaient
capables d'apprendre et de comprendre
des concepts aussi complexe que les
émotions il était capable de les
reconnaître chez eux chez leurs
camarades et même chez moi je me
souviens d'ailleurs dû maîtresse tu as
vraiment lampe l'air contrarié ça se
voit sur ton visage
ça m'a bluffé je sentais bien que
quelque chose se passait aujourd'hui
j'ai la réponse et ce sont les
neurosciences qui nous éclairent le
simple fait de nommer une émotion permet
déjà de pouvoir l'accueillir la
comprendre et la calmer ses besoins
mais lire des albums de jeunesse ça ne
suffit pas on a donc décidé de créer des
activités autour des mes émotions notre
préféré la mosaïque des émotions alors
chaque jour les élèves pouvaient
indiquer leurs émotions on positionne en
une image est sur le mur cet exercice
quotidien auquel je me prêtait moi-même
avec assiduité a été l'occasion de
prendre conscience de l'impact des
émotions des leurs et deviennent dans la
journée deux places c'était un réel
outil pour moi je joue le jeu avec
sincérité
alors au début en guise d'exemple pour
les élèves mais au fur et à mesure je
les fais pour moi je me passais au scan
des émotions chaque jour je me posais je
ressentais un temps unique une
parenthèse dans le cycle infernal de mes
journées en plus en un coup d'oeil je
pouvais jauger de la disponibilité de
mes élèves en effet un enfant joyeux
heureux était plus rapidement à l'écouté
disponible qu'un élève triste et en
colère
logique comment demander à un enfant
sous l'emprise de ses émotions être à
l'écouté et attentifs
d'ailleurs à ce sujet les neurosciences
nous explique que les jeunes enfants
sont dans l'incapacité de gérer les
tempêtes émotionnel ils sont submergés
par leurs émotions parce que leur
cerveau est encore dans un processus de
construction
sachant ça j'avais développé plus de
patience
j'étais à présent plus à l'écouté je
comprenais encore mieux pourquoi les
enfants n'étaient pas capables de se
contrôler
la mosaïque des émotions a été une
première étape dans l'accompagnement des
élèves elle m'a permis de tisser des
liens solides bases et sur l'accueil et
l'écouté mutuelle modifiant
considérablement
nous relations dans la classe
j'ai commencé à apprécier le temps passé
avec les élèves oui oui je vous la sueur
et la nuit je me contentais uniquement
de l'alphabet d'exorciste c'était union
alors pour susciter l'intérêt de mes
élèves vers ces nouveaux comportements
j'ai décidé avec eux de commencer à les
récompenser
quelle erreur les récompenses reste des
sanctions alors positive pour l'élève
qui la reçoit mais négatives pour celui
qui en est privée les dérives n'ont pas
tardé et c'était la course aux points et
chacun pour soi ma chance
une deuxième formation toujours sur la
base du volontariat mais cette fois ci
il n'était pas question d'apprendre à
complimenter les élèves à les
récompenser il était question
d'apprendre à les encourager et j'ai
compris une chose essentielle
le but de l'accompagnement des élèves et
de leur permettre de développer une
confiance en eux que cette confiance ne
soit pas dépendante du jugement des
autres
keller appartiennent qu elle soit
intrinsèque
je pense d'ailleurs à cet enfant elle
avait particulièrement attiré mon
attention
les points pour elle n'avait aucune
importance elle était persuadée qu'elle
n'aurait jamais à cinq ans elle avait
déjà développé une imposture d'une élève
effacés
elle avait une très faible estime
d'elle-même elle se pensait souvent
incapables de réaliser des activités
proposées alors j'ai décidé d'appliquer
ce que vous avez expliqué en formation
rien de bien extraordinaire du bon sens
prendre le temps lui offrir un sourire
un commentaire sur ses progrès et ses
réussites en quelques jours seulement je
les ai vus se métamorphoser j'ai vu son
corps entier manifester sa présence et
sa confiance en elle je pense aussi à
cette autre élève il n'avait pas fait
ses devoirs il semblait très inquiet
il avait mûrement réfléchi ses
justifications alors c'était bien trop
dur bien trop difficile personne ne
l'avait aidé et
je les regarder droit dans les yeux et
avec un large sourire je lui y est
assurée que j'étais certaines de ses
capacités qu'en essayant il allait y
arriver et que m ils allaient pouvoir
corriger les d'activité pour ses
camarades il m'a regardé d'un oeil tour
en mai je lui ai offert le temps pour
qu'il puisse se rendre compte par lui
même ça n'a pas loupé au bout de
quelques instants la satisfaction
personnelle s'est manifestée sur son
message la prophétie auto-réalisatrice
sa complice et il avait réussi et il en
était fier tout simplement parce qu'ils
s'étaient sentis soutenus
considéré et en confiance
aujourd'hui
j'enseigne en fait main je tente
toujours la main mais plus du tout dans
les mêmes intentions et j'ai adopté la
proche c'est à la psychologie positive
que j'ai emprunté notre nouveau rituel
les élèves s'écrivent des messages
positifs
chaque jour ils s'écrivent un message et
c'est assez bluffant de voir se
manifester chez eux leurs capacités
naturelles d'être sensible et aller
coûte ils sont hyper observateurs ayant
souvent le mot juste un jour le message
était le suivant
tu es une belle personne d'en sourire et
et rayonnant et il me fait beaucoup de
bien
ça j'étais réceptive à ce message moi
même devinez quoi il m'était destinée ça
m'a bouleversé et en même temps samar
booster pour toute la journée j'ai
compris pourquoi il avait autant d'
enthousiasme pour cette activité qui
était un simple exercice pour moi mais
pour eux une activité génératrice d'un
profond plaisir
les activités basées sur les émotions et
la connaissance de soi sont entrés un
peu partout dans les classes dans le
monde mais elle reste encore très peu
institutionnalisée dans le système
français alors oui elles prennent du
temps au début mais sur le long terme
les résultats sont considérables les
élèves apprennent à s'entraider il
expérimente la solidarité l'empathie la
bienveillance si bien qu'aujourd'hui je
ne suis plus la seule à être celles qui
encouragent dans ma classe les échanges
sont sereins les élèves rentrent avec
joie dans les activités on gagne du
temps et il est résultats sont au rendez
vous les solutions étaient là
si simple si accessible
désormais je fais ce que j'aime je
ressens ja campagne j'encourage et
surtout je dors tellement mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]